[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him do you think he's actually going to
dress up as the wiener of the house you
like a wiener costume [__] Halloween
I don't know I mean he's acting like a
total little
dick what a [__]
[__] holding up funding for our Ally
Israel he's going to uncouple Ukraine
funding uh from this funding bill and
he's going to be like Hey Joe Biden you
got to give my rich billionaire friends
the ability to cheat on their taxes or
I'm not going to give funding to our
allies in
democracy welcome to the Tony Michaels
podcast as you know I am the Tony
Michaels it is October 31st happy
Halloween happy Halloween here at the
Tony Michaels podcast U but I don't know
how happy it is I don't know it's um
it's it's very weird this morning it's
very weird I'd love to talk about
American politics this morning but the
foreign politics politics are bleeding
into the American politics faster and
faster at a heavier Pace the reason why
is because the conflict in Gaza is
getting more
heated
so as the Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin testifies in front of the senate
committee this morning more and more
protesters in the room are strategically
protesting I'm going to show you scenes
of that and again I've told you that
Humanity is the first thing on the
list in this conflict but Hamas is
making that very [__] difficult very
difficult and people around the world
are getting confused about who's killing
who I believe that's my personal belief
now again I know a lot of people aren't
going to have the same stance that I'm
going to have here on the show in this
conflict I completely understand that I
get that and the reason why is because
there are children being killed there
are innocent civilians being killed in
these acts of
War but I think a lot of people are
pointing fingers at the wrong folks of
who is
responsible for the deaths of these
innocent civilians in Gaza I'm going to
show you a video today of an interview
that was done of these Hamas
tunnels I showed you uh a clip yesterday
of Hillary Clinton the email lady
her
emails you know the email lady was
pretty much correct about
everything and really we failed
ourselves uh when we did not elect her
president she's a shitty retail
politician right oh she's horrible at
that she's horrible at the retail
politics and she's horrible at you know
projecting an an image of likability and
um not to be such a
damn policy-driven robot but that's what
Hillary Clinton is so you know you take
it or leave it but the the point is is
that she's one of the smartest people
that we've ever had in politics she's
one of the smartest people we've ever
had at that level of
government she was the Secretary of
State she knows these issues inside and
out forward and
backward and not only that she
understands the context she understands
the history and she's very careful about
how she forms
the policy opinions that she had when
she was in
government she was thoughtful oh [__]
ain't that about a
[__] but my belief is is that we were
Derick in our duty as a democracy when
we decided that it was a good
idea to put the buffoon in charge of our
country maybe led us to the world that
we have today I mean it's possible you
know we could get in to the time machine
and fire up the old flux capacitor and
go back in time and try to think about
how it would and you could have been but
going forward that doesn't do us a lot
of
good just like in Gaza it doesn't do the
civilians a lot of good to try to turn
back
time to try to give context to the rest
of the world as civilians in Gaza are
slaughtered because Hamas is picking
strategic
positions where
a where they're fired upon kills
civilians so they can
propagate how Israelis are killing
civilians in
Gaza to
breed sympathy for Hamas and sympathy
for their cause and their terrorist ways
to kill Jewish people to eliminate
Jewish people and I know I know it it's
weird right like we're in this weird
position where you have to try to
defend well I can't Tony I can't defend
children and civilians getting killed
I'm not asking you to do that [__] I
don't want that
either but it's not it's not it's not
the
Israelis you know that Hamas has a huge
tunnel system 60 M below the surface
that's where Hamas
is Hamas surfaces to fire upon Israel
from these strategic positions so that
they retaliate because that's what they
do and they pick these strategic
positions so that the propaganda is that
their people are being
slaughtered Hamas is not picking
military positions to fire from folks
I hate I hate to be the bearer of the
[__]
truth but it would be like in this
country if our military was firing on
our
enemy and they they strategically picked
hospitals and churches and
schools knowing that the fire in
retaliation will have
catastrophic consequences to the
civilian population in those
areas we wouldn't do that if we did not
have
to we would fire from
positions that were military
positions positions of
defense that is not what Hamas is doing
and they're not only terrorizing the
Israeli people because they're
Jewish they're using the slaughter of
their people to advance their cause to
kill more Jewish people in Israel that's
the [__] truth and if you don't like
it that's fine that's fine if you don't
like the truth I don't like the truth
either I really don't like it it would
be great if we could come up with some
kind of [__] delusional
reality where we could just say oh yeah
just we'll just stop we'll just stop
we'll just not do this thing but this is
what theology
does I keep saying it over and over on
this show that the American people don't
really understand really people
worldwide but American people really
don't understand ideology they don't get
it they haven't been taught what
ideology
is they don't even really honestly don't
even know what theology is it's wild
stuff these people say Wild crazy [__]
that the Bible doesn't even say I mean a
good example is [__] Mike Johnson why
on Mike Johnson for a minute just a
minute I'm gonna get back to this I
promise why in the [__] is there is
there United States
Representatives when they're single men
adopting adopting teenage
boys and not officially adopting just
like oh yeah he's my son wink
that's [__] weird right am I off my
rocker is this I mean come on I'm am I
am I crazy
here Mike Johnson wasn't married when he
adopted his 14-year-old son boy he
adopted a 14-year-old boy it's not his
son he didn't adopt
him mcats did the same thing what the
[__] is going
on
how I I just is
this I never heard of this being a
problem until we' seen mat gats and then
now Mike Johnson anyway any who anywh
who a lot of people are like well you
know you're getting distracted by the
issue of whether he adopted a Bo a
14-year-old boy or not and I'm like
distracted I think that's something that
we need to know about this guy is the
third in line to the presidency it would
be nice to know why this guy
adopted a 14-year-old boy that now he
doesn't even claim as part of his family
I mean in a new I guess in a in a new
statement he's he's saying that he
didn't actually officially adopt him
it's [__] weird stuff I don't know
but it is there are Republicans or white
Christian nationalists it's all [__]
weird seems like a lot of skeletons in
his closet you know Denny hazard
he was he was the longest serving
speaker in the house [__] went
to federal prison for paying hush money
for trying to cover up his sex
crimes with u with his wrestling team
sound familiar no I'm not talking about
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan I'm
talking about an actual speaker someone
who actually won the speaker vote Denny
Hazard what are we going to find out
about speaker Mike Johnson later on in
life huh huh what we going to find out
about
him but speaker Johnson is holding up
the funding for our Ally
Israel in their defense of course the
Republicans in the house have completely
abandoned the idea that they're going to
fund Ukraine it's really it's really
[__] something ain't it that the
Republicans in the house absolutely are
Putin's
puppets I mean if you think about it g
give me just a second here if you think
about
it the Republicans in the house don't
want to fund the effort of Ukraine to
defend their democracy against Putin and
his murderous
regime marching into their country and
trying to take their Sovereign
territory and trying to overthrow their
democracy no matter how how corrupt it
may be but then now now Mike Johnson's
like Hey Joe Biden if you want funding
for Israel to defend itself you have to
give my rich billionaire donors more
their money that they owe to the
government did you hear about this
that's what this motherfucker's
doing listen Russia is funding Iran Iran
is funding Hamas so essentially Putin is
Hamas Hamas is Putin funded right and
now Mike Johnson not only doesn't want
to give money to Ukraine but he doesn't
give want to give money to Israel
and he wants cash in the exchange of the
extortion of the [__] slaughtered
people in Ukraine and in Gaza and Israel
he wants cash in his billionaire donor
Pockets I'm not [__] you this is
[__] real now you know a lot of
people aren't going to say it like I say
it they're just
not but this [__] is going to
put blood
money in his donor's pocket
now in the inflation reduction
act the federal government the IRS was
given the ability to go after
billionaire tax cheats [__]
that try to skate on taxes and basically
giving funding to the IRS to get our
money that we're owed by these rich
[__] pieces of
trash the 1% the ones that [__] use
rooms full of lawyers to confuse the IRS
to save themselves hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of millions of dollars in
taxes every year that's our
money that's ours it's our government
it's our Collective that's part of our
[__] GDP that we should be putting in
the education and Roads and the social
safety
net I talked about just yesterday about
[__] the infrastructure of public
schools feeding children godamn just a
fraction a fraction of the amount of
money that is going to be collected from
Mike Johnson's
donors from these IRS agents actually
being able to do their [__] job and
catch these tax cheats and get our
[__] money would probably pay for
children's food at school lunch for
decades and Mike Johnson Mike Johnson is
holding that as
extortion
telling the Biden Administration either
you [__] either you [__] stop you
either stop looking into my tax cheap
billionaire donors or you're not going
to get your funding for
Israel blood money in the pockets of
American
billionaires just shows you who [__]
owns Mike Johnson doesn't it just shows
you who owns the Republicans this is his
first go at something folks
he a even been a speaker a [__] week
has he and this motherfucker's all
already pouring money blood money into
billionaires
Pockets holy [__] over the weekend I
can't imagine the phone calls that Mike
Johnson got over the weekend from his
donors now that you're the Speaker of
the House
[__] you're going to make sure
that we get all our money that we could
cheat on our [__] taxes
better do it now [__] I don't care what
you got to hold
hostage now you know who owns Mike
Johnson and the Republicans in the house
as if we didn't already [__] know
this
[__] we've been telling the country this
for [__]
years decades we've been telling
them and I I know that you know the
Democratic party obviously has its own
billionaires and its own special
interest but God
damn I mean this isn't even think about
this this isn't even uh like an offset
that's what they're trying to present it
as they're trying to sell it on the
trader TV news networks as some sort of
offsetting cost right so in other words
oh this Aid to Israel is going to cost x
amount of dollars so what we'll do is
we'll take this funding from the IRS
that is designed to decrease the deficit
and uses as an offset so
literally this this plan of Mike Johnson
and his billionaire Blood Money tax tax
cheating
donors is GNA cause us to have more
national debt not less it's not a pay
for because we're going to collect
less taxes that we are owed anyways from
these rich
[__] but that's the plan that's
the Republican plan is to convince their
[__]
sheep that we can't fund Israel unless
we pay for it the way we pay for it is
not go after the rich billionaire tax
cheats so that way they can pay us less
money that they owe us [__]
boneheaded
[__] but this is the [__] this is the
garbage that the Sheep will eat
I I don't I think this is dead in the
Senate I think it's dead on Biden's desk
even if it would make it through the
Senate because apparently glitch
McConnell that stroke ridden Turtle I
don't even know why the [__] he's still
a senator let alone the minority
leader but Mitch McConnell apparently is
having meetings with Mike Ro Johnson the
wiener of the house to try to convince
him that he definitely should couple is
Israeli and Ukrainian Aid
together because even glitch McConnell
as he rides through who knows how many
dozen mini strokes a
day he still understands the threat of
Putin and the threat that Putin poses to
democracy holy [__] can you imagine Tony
Michaels sitting here being on the side
of glitch McConnell we are in Wild
weird times
folks and it is a struggle for our
democracy it is a struggle for democracy
around the world because the
misinformation is [__] just a
waterfall and people are falling for the
misinformation like [__]
crazy back to the conflict in Gaza
because I know a lot of people a lot of
people are going to disagree with me a
lot of people are going to hate the [__]
I
say but this morning I was listening to
the to the Senate
hearing and I was listening to Blink and
speak and I was listening to the
protesters in the
room and I actually heard
something that made me feel proud proud
of this
country that's right proud of this
country as secretary blinkin sits there
and reports to the Senate hearing and to
the
Senate on what he's doing in his plans
for the state
department in Gaza in the
conflict that the Palestinian people and
Israeli people are working through
because Hamas is a terrorist
organization they protesters
strategically in the room
protesting there's nothing more American
than
that and I I hear those people in the
room
crying crying for a
ceasefire and I know
why and I I wish that it could be
realistic that their protest could come
to fruition and could there could be a
ceasefire but it is
not it is not going to help the
Palestinian
people Hamas is a terrorist organization
they are hiding in tunnels
folks they're a well
organized welle
equipped military
unit these are not [__] civilians
running
around now the civilians in Gaza the
Palestinian
a lot of them have been propagandized to
believe that Hamas is their protector
because in 2007 when Hamas took power
they suspended all
elections how are we expected to have
Palestinians that understand the truth
that they don't have the liberty for
truth it's the design of
Hamas and the Arab world has left the
Palestinians out to
dry because the Arab world World
supports
Hamas and you can shake it however the
[__] you want to shake it but there is a
lot of Truth and a lot of the truths
you're not going to like I don't [__]
like them I was listening to these
people protesting in the Senate chamber
this morning crying out for the children
that are being killed in
Gaza and it's
heartbreaking that Hamas is coming out
of the tunnels and firing from these
positions so that there will be received
fire to kill civilians to kill
children they're heavily
organized they're
strategic in their
operations they are a terrorist
organization and they hold a hate in
their heart for a people because of
theology
in this
war as much as it's driven by
religion it is driven by an ideology
that has lived with us for
centuries and it is picking its head out
all over the world in little towns where
people are being stabbed there's being
violence not just not just against
Jewish people but against Muslims
it's sad to say that humans are trash
but
godamn we can't get our [__]
together and if we can't tell the truth
about
this then shame on
us it is a goddamn travesty that people
in Gaza especially
children who don't even know the history
of the war who have been convinced that
Hamas are their protectors what else
would they
know but that [__] propaganda from
these
terrorist and then to be strategically
used as targets because that's the
[__]
truth you may not like the truth but
it's the [__]
truth you should we should free
Palestine we should free Palestinians
from
Hamas from the Arab world using them as
a cudel to advance their hatred and
Advance their war on Jewish people all
around the
world and I feel for the protesters
because I I can't imagine the
slaughter I can't imagine Hamas
not celebrating as their own people are
killed as they get to propagandize more
that it's the Israelis picking these
positions I'm going to show you a video
of their t a part of their tunnel system
today I'm going to show it to you now
rather you look at it or
not and see it and believe it you know
it's up to you because right now you
probably should [__] question everything
you see on the screen every [__] bit
of it it's going to get
wild but I'm going to show you a
video of these
tunnels I'm probably not going to Blade
the audio because it's in a different
language it's subtitle but I don't I
don't want to sit there and read it you
can go watch the video but I'm going to
show you what these tunnels look
like and where they're
hiding and why it's so important
that we understand what our role the
United States role is in this
conflict and is to stand on the side of
democracy no matter how shitty that
democracy may be look I'm no friend of
[__] BB Netanyahu [__] that guy [__]
that right-wing piece of trash [__]
him unfortunately right now in this
moment he's the lead
the Israelis had picked to lead them why
[__] there's a lot of questions in that
and why would they stand back and let
him [__] beat up their democracy from
within is beyond me but this is what
right-wingers do they try to destroy
democracies why do you think in h in
Gaza Hamas won the election in 2007 and
immediately suspended all of their
elections because they're a right-wing
[__] terrorist organization
that's right they're a right-wing
terrorist
organization and they're oppressing the
Palestinian people they're letting their
[__] people get slaughtered so that
they can use it as a cudel to advance
the opportunity to kill Jewish
people and exterminate Jewish
people you don't think war is for
hate there is no [__] Love and
War
but the fact that American people are
still willing to go and speak out in a
senate hearing and disrupt the Senate
hearing
strategically it gives me hope for
descent because folks that's important I
know a lot of you disagree with me and I
know a lot of you will will disagree
with me in the comments and you will
send comments on YouTube and Twitter and
and the DMS and keep them
coming I think descent
is the
foundation of liberal
democracy and who else will protect
those children if not your
descent and if not The Descent in the
Senate
chamber a lot of things can be true at
once and sometimes the truth is not easy
and sometimes the
truth isn't something that we want to
deal with but if we don't deal with the
truth
now if we don't deal with the reality
now there will be more
Slaughter there will be more
die whether it be the Palestinian people
whether it be the Israeli people or just
people in the Arab world in
general we must hold Humanity first
don't go anywhere it's Tuesday it's
Halloween I'll be right back right after
these
messages we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a magga
Edition I knew I had to give it a try
Babel Maga Edition makes it really easy
to learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacist the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that I'm
struggling with I chose Babel mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives
matter jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show Happy
Halloween happy
Tuesday uhoh we got an image in
the lab rat is at
work yes that's right we got small rat
in the background he's here on Halloween
I think he's wearing I think he's
wearing a costume today and he's got a
he's got an image it's a live image of
the Republican puppets in their
costume oh boy let's take a look uh a
small rat do you have do you have an
image for us is that is that what you
got oh look at at your costume today
that's really
sweet happy
hallowe looks like you're celebrating
Halloween in a donatell costume
yeah rical radical radical radical
that's great that's great so you got an
image for us though right you got an
image for us all right it looks like I
mean I like your Halloween costume but I
almost like these Republicans costumes
much better let's take a look here oh
look look they're all in their little
Putin's puppets costumes oh boy oh
perfect Halloween costumes for the
Republican caucus now they're dressed up
as Putin's puppets today for Halloween
thank you r i I really like your costume
I mean
donatell that's right that's right
Leonardo leads donatell does machines
all right well stay in the background I
know you're working over there in the
lab um and if we need you I'll I'll go
to the lab thank you R thank you all
right all right we got 's let me give
you one more look of the
Putin's puppet costumes here it looks
like the house concus is dressed up here
as Putin's puppets speaking of dressed
up did you know we have new merch that's
right we have new merch let me show it
to you here at the Tony Michaels go to
the Tony michaels.com you can get your
this machine kills fascist tattoo merch
that's right this is going to be the
inspiration for the tattoo that is going
to go on my arm in January and you can
get a piece of it there's hoodies
there's t-shirts there's coffee mugs
check it out go to the Tony michaels.com
scroll down to the tattoo merch
collection and also we have this one
inspired by the the deric sen senator in
Texas even my dog hates Ted
Cruz I guess I said this on a podcast
one day and Margie said that should be
merch well your wish is my command so go
to Theon michaels.com pan on down you
will find even my dog hates Ted merch
check it out there at dton mich.com
click I appreciate all the support and I
really like this merch I really like the
new merch the tattoo is like we work so
hard on this design and I super excited
about it I'm super excited about getting
the finalized design of the tattoo and
getting it tattooed on my arm I'm going
to take pictures and videos this thing
while we're doing it uh but I can't wait
to get my t-shirt my hoodie and some of
my other merch but speaking of Ted Cruz
and even my dog hitting dead cruise from
Texas it's Tuesday we have Texas Paul
Texas Paul how are you today my friend I
am wonderful my friend I am wonderful
I'm so glad Monday is over that is a
goodlooking hoodie that really is you
like you like you like that that's
pretty [__] sweet Ain it absolutely
that is
that is really good looking here's the
one here's the one that's got the logo
on the front so we got one with the logo
on the front one with the the the art on
the back um so we're super excited about
the tattoo merch here on the yeah man
and I and I got and I have got to
applaud you brother the the graphics
have been fantastic you have just been
upping the bar on the show for a while
for a long while this is this is um this
is all in due to the lab rat we have uh
hanging out with us
uh you know here he is hey hey rat
there's rat in his Halloween costume
there yeah Thumbs Up and Good job yeah
so uh everything's been going swimmingly
here let me show you uh here here's rat
in his laboratory today uh you know he's
he's kind of working in there today here
he is Texas Paul in his laboratory today
he's in his Halloween costume working
back there getting all the images done
for us look at he's got it all decorated
for Halloween and everything
and oh boy we're fast quick and in a
hurry on this Texas Paul have you heard
about the micro
Johnson holding up funding for Israel
because he wants his fat cat donors to
pay less in taxes have you heard this
yeah absolutely absolutely what do you
think about holding bleaching
me what do you think about him holding
in hostage oh man that that is so
typical that is so damn typical you know
one minute they're all like oh we stand
with Israel we stand with Israel and
then they're like ah we're going to
Blackmail you Israel gets no funding uh
Palestinians get no funding Ukraine gets
no funding unless the guy that writes me
checks you know every every couple
months gets a tax break I mean that's
that's just the Republican grift man
it's it's what they are well I mean they
are they are grifters but more than that
they're grifters for their their Rich
base I mean that's why why they're put
there it it's no more obvious now than
than ever of what this is about when
Mike Johnson became the speaker is his
first the first thing they want him to
do is get rid of the IRS agents here he
is talking to kayy mckin on Fox News
let's take a listen to what he was
saying in his interview now let's talk
about one of those areas of common
ground potentionally this isra Aid
package Standalone Israel Aid the
reporting is that there will be a vote
hopefully Thursday is that the timeline
you're looking at I'm hoping Thursday
and it looked like 14.5 billion is the
number that you're looking at and you
suggest that maybe you'll get a
bipartisan vote here sure hope do you
have any sense of the number of
Democrats who you think might come I
hope that it's most or all of them I
mean there's a few people who have
philosophical differences on that and
we'll have some intense debates about
their opposition to that but look this
is a matter of good versus evil how is
it going to be paid for um we're going
to be releasing that here short shortly
but um we my intention and my desire in
the first uh draft of this bill is to
take some of the money that has been set
aside for the IR building and bulking up
the IRS right now they have about 67
billion dollar in that fund and we'll
we'll try to take the 14.5 necessary for
this immediate and urgent need we'll
deal with the rest of that issue later
do you think that will drive all right
so there it is that's where that's where
he's going to take the funding from and
obviously he he believes that he can
pull uh the wool over the Sheep's eyes
and by that I mean Republican supporters
Trump supporters MAA uh he's going to
try to pull the wool over their eyes
because they're going to believe yeah
this is good because now I won't have
IRS agents beating on my door like you
don't make enough money and pay enough
taxes for the IRS to use any of this
money to come after you you dumb son of
a [__] what it is is it's money that is
allocated for the IRS to go after the
billionaires and tax cheats in this
country the richest tax cheats in this
country of where they owe us money
anyways it's money they [__] [__]
already owe us which is going to
increase the deficit Texas Paul so this
isn't going to this isn't going
to be a a a a a a money neutral exchange
for the Israeli funding it's going to
cost us more money doing it this
way yeah absolutely I mean absolutely
it's and it's again another payoff to
their Mega donors that cheat on their
taxes let's [__] the IRS as much as
possible you know it's it's it's
freaking ridiculous and the the way that
your average Joe Falls for this is
freaking amazing man I mean everybody
hates taxes Tony everybody hates taxes I
mean you hate them I hate them everybody
nobody want pay tax yeah right you know
but we kind of like our roads and [__]
we kind of like you know being safe we
kind of like the fact that our country
is so stable that everybody comes here
to put their money here you know I mean
we we like all that [__] but we don't
like to pay the taxes but these guys man
I tell you they're they they're just no
holdes bar just openly out in the open
pandering to their to their donors and
then you've got the little guy that's
like oh yeah do that do that it's like
guy come on man the IRS doesn't give a
[__] about you they get a random print
out every year of who they're going to
audit they didn't pick on you it's just
random you know and unless of course
you've triggered something you've done
something to make them look at you you
know which the average guy doesn't you
know I mean you just it's it's all just
copy numbers for your average guy and
and and they're sitting there thinking
okay yeah we're going to [__] the IRS
and and keep them from coming after me
they're not coming after I had a family
member get audited
Tony he had more money coming back they
wrote him a check at the end of the
audence because he because he ended up
not reporting what he should have
reported to get the money that he needed
and the government owed him money the
government owed him the auditor the
auditor was sitting with him and there's
like why didn't you claim this you know
why didn't you claim you know why didn't
you depreciate this and he's like well I
didn't want to get audited and just like
that's stupid you're well you're already
being audited right right now you're
being audited yeah you know here's
here's the thing too that I that I think
is telling about uh Mike Johnson and how
he's doing this because this plan was
kind of uh spoken on Fox News he he he's
not saying this to his caucus he's not
saying this out loud uh Mike Johnson is
a [__] puppet 100% but which leads me
to the weird history of Mike Johnson and
how we got here because three weeks ago
Mike Johnson or anyone in the universe
of Republican politics never ever
dreamed that Mike Johnson would be the
speaker of the house not only is he not
qualified he's never worked his way in
leadership to even be the speaker but
this weird thing in his history where he
adopted a 14-year-old boy um this is
weird stuff and of course the internet's
talking about this they're speculating
on this they're speculating about Mike
Johnson rather maybe he's closeted um
he's definitely a christop fascist he
he's a white Christian nationalist 100%
And for some weird reason he keeps
saying he's GNA govern based on the
Bible which is weird anyways because
there's so many contradictions in the
Bible that it's hard to even imagine
that it'd be a govern document but what
do you make what do you make of the
internet of Buzz about the 14 I it's
hard for me to even say without getting
grossed out the 14-year-old boy that the
single man Mike Johnson adopted 22 years
ago yeah that's creepy as hell man that
I mean that's red flags I mean just
blowing up in every falling everywhere
like glitter man that is that is really
freaking scary that is I mean why would
a 25y old old single he was single at
the time he was not married uh take on a
14-year-old boy I just it's right you
know it's one thing you know Tony if
there was like a family story you know
like like hey one of your best friends
passes away or they get killed a car
wreck and you're like okay I'm GNA take
on their son to raise this ain't that
this is not that this is he went out and
shopped him up a little 14-year-old boy
to bring into his house and people was
starting to ask why and you know as well
as I do that dude gives off Vibes like
he can just intimately describe what
Narnia looks
like oh my god well you know I I get I
got to thinking about it and I you know
for obvious reasons I was like now wait
a second there's another there's another
Rising manga star who is a who is a
piece of trash who did the same thing
who claims he did the same thing being a
single man in his 20s uh adopting and
again I use air quotes like Don Jr but
not like Don Jr I use them appropriately
here because actually uh Matt gats
didn't adopt Nester the the the teenage
boy that he claims he adopted and
apparently Mike Johnson didn't
officially adopt and is admitting it
that he didn't officially adopt Michael
which is apparently the the the man now
but the 14year old boy's name then um
that still doesn't appear with him and
still doesn't seem to support him and
still doesn't yeah there's some weird
[__] going on there man right so what is
what is is there something to this like
is this a republican thing I've never
heard of this before to be honest with
you where a a a 20-some year old single
man adopts a teenage boy I've never
heard of this before and I thought it
was just like a Matt Gat thing but it
seems to be like a republican
Congressman thing I don't know Am I
Wrong what the [__] is going on it seems
like it doesn't it I mean it really
seems like they all go out shopping and
pick up a kid to help around the house
or something I don't know I mean it's
just it you know it's going to come out
though Tony you know it is and it just
kills me how these people will take
these jobs with this kind of [__]
flagrant flagrantly in their background
they will take these jobs and I I don't
know if they lie to themselves or what
that people aren't going to look at this
you know I mean you I mean I mean
honestly we weren't because without Mike
Johnson RI weird rise to power here Mike
Johnson would have just continued being
some dumbass Congress person from
Louisiana never been noticed if he
wouldn't have been like oh well there's
no one else that'll be speakers so let's
get this weirdo who adopted a who who
who took on a 14-year-old boy when he
was single in his 20s it's weird stuff
but we wouldn't know about this if Mike
Johnson wouldn't have put his hat in the
ring if I could say it like
that truth man 100% truth and that
that's the part that just blows my
freaking mind it's like okay we're going
to make think think about you're the
Republican caucus okay did they do no
research on anybody they were trying to
put Byron Donalds in there a guy that
got busted for dealing drugs they were
trying to make him speaker of the house
like that wasn't going to come out you
know I mean and and and he committed
bankrupt then you you know wait wait I'm
gonna say I would much rather have a
former drug dealer than a [__]
traffic a human trafficker I'm just
saying I'm I'm just saying a little bit
of lowl drug dealing even if it has to
do with you know a little bit of you
know some other scrupulous things is a
lot different than human trafficking I
don't and again I don't know what Mike
Johnson was doing with a for 14-year-old
boy but I it even when I say it out loud
it sounds really weird that the new
speaker of the house when he was
25 adopted a 14-year-old boy it sounds
really weird when I say it yeah I and I
agree with you wholeheartedly on that
point I do I I don't think you know I
don't think like a low-level drug bust
when you're young does anything to your
overall career but vetting man vetting
this is this is this is not Bush League
politics this is The Big Show I mean did
they not but isn't it but isn't it isn't
it more telling about how they're
scraping at the bottom of the MAA Barrel
really I mean isn't that kind of the
narrative here is that there's no one
else that wants to be a leader in this
party because this party is dead this
party is [__] dead I mean so much so
that Mitch mccon is the savior for
Ukraine funding the guy can't even wake
up in the morning and get through half
the day without having a half a dozen
mini strokes and glitching but he's
going to be the savior of the Republican
party to to to to be the voice of reason
for democracy around the world and not
capitulate to Putin holy [__] that's
that's our defense come on this is
ridiculous great Point great point but
I've got to ask you something man can I
please use glitch McConnell because
abely glitchy glitchy glitchy that is
perfect use the [__] out of that but but
yeah you make a great Point Tony I mean
it's these guys are just and what's
scary is if you try to think about
inside baseball there are actual
conversations going on between Hakeem
jeffy's office and Mike Johnson's office
where Mike Johnson is telling Hakeem
Jeff I can't get this funding through
without making a huge concession to our
Mega donors because I can't control my
caucus
the only thing that they will all vote
for is that you give somebody a massive
ass tax cut that's well yeah because
they can go to their donors and justify
that right right right because they
don't need to go to their constituents
and justify it because they'll just lie
to the constituency they'll just totally
[__] lie to the Sheep to get the
Sheep to vote for them for whatever the
hell they need to vote for them for
that's what they'll do and a lot of
these districts that's the other reason
why Mike Johnson is the speaker of the
house is because he's in a safe District
in the Louisiana and because you can't
have and it's politics
101 what you can't do is have a leader
of your party caucus inside a governing
body you can't have them be not a secure
seat because you can't afford the look
of them voting out your uh your leaders
of the party in some sort of primary or
a small general election um the last the
last imagery of this was somebody like
that happen well yeah but this this was
uh this was years ago the first the
first sign that the Republican party was
really being handed over to the to the
extremist was when Eric caner who was
third in charge who was third in line in
the Republican gaonas Eric caner lost
his primary bout with an extremist um
and that's in Virginia and that's really
where it started that's where this
that's the that was the first sign of
trouble in the Republican party that it
was being handed over to extremists um
but I but I mean that's another reason
why you know mikro Johnson here the
wiener of the house was elected let's
finish up this clip because I think even
Kaylee mckin pushes back on him here
which is wild stuff but let's watch away
some Democrats in the Senate even or
here in the house it may but my
intention is to call leader Schumer over
there and have a very uh direct and
thoughtful conversation about this I
understand their priority is to bulk up
the IRS um but I think if you put this
to the American people and they weigh
the two needs I think they're going to
say standing with Israel and protecting
the innocent uh over there is in our
national interest and is a more
immediate need than IRS
agents um so again she does give him
enough push back but so and a false
dichotomy right exactly there isn't an
either or there there isn't an either or
there you know I mean you can't have an
IRS and you can't support Israel I mean
right right well and and when he says
we're going to go sell this to the
American people what means is is we're
going to go sell this to the Sheep um
and and when the Sheep when we have
videos and and and you know um um just
affirmation from 12% of the country who
will believe anything we tell them um
then it's then it's the truth then it's
the American people right who are
supporting this which the American
people don't support this honestly the
American people want more IRS funding to
go after [__] Rich ass tax cheats
they're sick and tired of it I mean we
just we saw this week that the last of
the big three fell to the American
working class the GM fell to the
American working class and they went
even further on their deal on uh
batteries apparently with the UAW uh so
and it appears that even more workers
and more Industries are appearing that
hey we need to strike um because this
American president is behind the
American workers and they will support
these strikes and they're winning the
workers are [__] winning against the
organization and the corporations and
Mike Johnson thinks that he's going to
sell this idea that what we should do is
make sure the IRS isn't going after
billionaires who are tax cheats to get
the money that we are owed in taxes we
the people the [__] government it's
us it's our [__] money that we are
owed based on the taxes that they owe us
the government he thinks he can sell
that idea well good [__] luck to him
I I actually kind of like this narrative
I and I said this on my show everyone
thinks that Mike Johnson is a big threat
to America which um he's he's a big
threat in that he is a piece of [__] and
he's a piece of trash but we still have
checks and balances and we have an
election coming up and if we don't want
him to be the speaker of the house by
God we just put our heads together and
we work our asses off and Hakeem jeffre
will be the Speaker of the House Amen
brother amen preach it preach it you are
spot on I mean you got to vote there's
an election going on to days
today know did you vote did did you go
out and vote I mean me and Mr Texas did
I mean talking about the the the the
audience here I mean did you get out and
vote I mean today's an election in your
area right um well and that's and that's
a good point is that we need to make
sure uh that we are the back stop to
democracy because we are we are the back
stop to democracy and and I know it it
feels weird but uh also I man I've got
an image coming in here um from uh from
Twitter here apparently Mitch McConnell
is making his way over to Mitch
McConnell is making his way over to the
new wiener of The house's office um to
pimp for Ukraine funding here I'm just
uh just finding this on
Twitter sometimes social media is good
and sometimes it's fantastic I'm not
going to lie it really is um you know so
who do you think is going to win this b
battle do you think Mitch mcconell will
win this battle or you think the new
wiener of the house will I actually
think the Wier of the house is going to
win this battle and I think there's not
going to be any Ukraine funding and I
think they're going to shut down the
government too if you want to know the
God's honest truth but you know a lot of
people don't agree with me yeah you're
good possibility everything you're
talking about might actually happen uh
if they can't sell this massive tax cut
uh there's no way Ukraine funding gets
through it doesn't it is
they're they're going to they're just
not going to do it that's the only way
they save face and and allow this to go
through if they don't get it through if
Mitch McConnell glitch McConnell can't
make his deal um then you you're gonna
lose one Co part of their caucus or the
other you've got the part of their
caucus that understands World politics
and World Dynamics and that Ukraine has
to Prevail here or you've got the crazy
caucus the chaos caucus who don't want
to fund Ukraine because they're all in
for Putin one or the other comes through
this a winter unless they can sell this
freaking tax cut which brings both of
them across and they can all sa face and
pretend to be a working caucus when
they're not right well that's where
we're at people bries or nothing gets
done uh speaking of glitch McConnell
Texas Paul we
haveit glitchy
[Music]
Mitchy that's that's what we do here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
now you you you ask and we deliver here
so there's glitchy Mitchy there's glitch
McConnell there on the you g were you
gonna talk about were you gonna talk the
preacher of The house's wife the
preacher of the
house mik Johnson that's what I call him
the preacher of the house no I call him
the wiener of the house cuz he's a
little CU he's a little Johnson
he's a little he's a little Johnson he's
a micro Johnson as we call him actually
we have a couple different names for him
but we've even got and we got a couple
different songs for him uh for him here
actually here he's the election denying
speaker of the house
too it's the election n speaker of the
house so he's election denying speaker
of the house too he's an insurrectionist
I don't know if you if you knew that
he's he definitely an
insurrectionist his wife deleted a bunch
of [__] oh really all of her yeah her
her lgbtq plus conversion therapy
website went down [__] okay we got to go
n into this tell me you do not know that
you're [__] a horrible human being uh
if you're deleting your own [__] tell me
that's not an an expression of guilt
that they know that this [__] is
horrific I mean she's comparing being
gay to beastiality and [__] like that
yeah man it's here here's here's
Tennessee holler update uh speaker Mike
Johnson's wife has taken down the
counseling service site that Likens
lgbtq plus people to people who have sex
with animals and family members oh man
she's a [__] religious zealot huh oh
who could have guessed that who could
have I did not see that coming I mean
this is what these people are they're
[__] Nazis uh it says here in The
Huffington Post Mike Johnson's wife
takes down the website that compared
being gay to beasti incest oh well son
of a [__] God damn there she is there
she is there's else are they hiding
there I mean if if that's the tagline if
that's the selling point imagine the
[__] that's going on behind the scenes
in her counseling service man I mean
again did did the Republicans not see
this coming did they not
that this is this was coming that that
this was going to be what their year of
the speaker is all about I mean did they
really think this guy was goingon to
lift their party I mean a guy that says
if you want to know what I think read
the Bible that's what I think you know I
mean Jesus Christ man I mean you know
Tony this is going to be our shows are
going to be [__] lit for the next
year because it's going to be one
scandal after another scand scandle
because you're going to have people come
that were in this that were forced into
this [__] that are come out are going to
come out and they're going to tell
horror stories about Mike Johnson's wife
and all these religious zealots always
have horrific [__] in their closet well
I don't know if you've seen this picture
and I wasn't when I first saw it I
didn't know if it was uh if it's real or
if it's
AI or is
it
I wasn't sure if it was real or if it's
AI but apparently it's real um and this
is uh Mike Johnson and his wife I don't
know if this is before right when they
were getting married but do you see how
he's leaning away from her and she
really has to lean into him I'm
wondering if I'm wondering if her little
conversion therapy counseling thing
wasn't designed for her husband I'm just
saying I'm just saying Mike look it's
you shouldn't be ashamed of it I know
your wife shames you because you're
probably that way but we're not going to
shame you if you're that way we won't we
won't uh I don't know I just you see a
couple that looks like this and you know
there are scandals coming out that she's
got she's getting her needs taken care
of somewhere you know that scandal's
coming out we we've got we've got the
son that they forever claimed they
adopted that they never really adopted
and he adopted him alone when he was 25
years old and this the the young man was
for so we know we got all kinds of
scandals falling out about this they're
deleting their Business website where
they you know abuse lgbtq plus people uh
so we know we've got scandals coming out
about that in the f I mean
geez just you
know Paul is breaking up I don't know if
it's if it's him or the internet
connection here but uh you're you're
breaking up just a bit
I want to show you a clip while your
service while your s comes back of Nancy
mace talking about here's her talking
about Mike Ro Johnson's wife a
conversion therapy gay hating wife here
here we go I sat down ear this week and
talked about some of the issues that I'm
very passionate about and trying to find
some common ground and he's a very
humble humble man and one of the issues
for example that I'm very passionate
about is is how we get Women Voters
Suburban women Suburban moms back into
the Republican Party back to vote for
for republicans and and keep our country
intact next year at the presidential
level and then also at Congress and the
Senate and you know he came up to me
this week and said I talked to my wife
and there are all these things that we
that we agree on whether it's safety in
schools hardening our schools whether
it's making sure that that moms and dads
have the resources that they need but
understanding that how we talk to people
really matters and our conserv ative
policies are the best policies for our
nation's Children and Families but it's
also how we talk to people and show
people that we care and he gets that and
the best thing about Mike that I can say
is he's just an honest guy
and well you know that's a [__] lie
he's got an R after his name Texas Paul
but you know a politician yeah he's
[__] honest right I want to go back
to what she said about his wife advising
him on how to get Suburban moms to vote
for Republicans number one this is very
telling when Nancy mace if you know
Nancy mace and the [__] she has said and
the [__] she spews and the and the
different narratives that she pushes on
different networks because she says one
thing on one network and another thing
on the network and Nancy mace is a lying
[__] trunt now I want to say that her
saying that Mike Johnson told her that
he talked to his wife and trying to
figure out a way to get Suburban moms
back to the Republic party let me tell
you something folks there is no better
[__] narrative in this country than
Mike Johnson and his wife that will well
make sure that [__] people go vote
Suburban moms go vote against
Republicans like against them like this
idea that he adopted a [__] 14year
old boy when he was 25 and she has some
sort of [__] conversion therapy thing
where she's comparing lgbtq people to to
people who participate in beastiality
let me tell you something that's one
thing that Suburban mom's going to be
like what the [__] are you kidding me
these are the people that they want me
to support and I this is not Suburban
mom type territory Texas Paul this just
isn't this is why Suburban moms in the
last elections have flocked to the
Democratic party because of the
craziness the absolute
extremist that manga has dumped on
them yeah Amen brother preach it amen
you know anytime somebody comes at you
with uh join me we're GNA save the
children watch out just watch out I mean
it's it's you know if if that is what
their selling point is watch out I mean
because look at Clan Karen Hood and all
the scandals and the Nazi [__] that's
been coming out thank God they got
utterly decimated in in in in the early
elections in in uh Tennessee thank God
but plan Caren Hood came out and when
they were going to save the children
then we turn out it's a bunch of Nazi
cryistal fascist uh Christian
nationalist
[__] always always When anybody I
don't care if it's left right middle of
the road whatever if they come out and
say you need to join me because we're
gonna save the
children slam on the brakes and look
around
right better start paying a [__]
tension uh if if you haven't been so it
um it's why wild stuff with the speaker
of the house um but there's some there's
some crazy stuff going on in the Senate
today and I I want to show the audience
some of this um and again margorie
Taylor green is calling the prop
Palestinian which I the prop Palestinian
protest which I'm not in full agreeance
with the pro U pro Palestinian protest
there in Washington I'm just not I think
um they're way too over the line and
they're bordering on supporting Hamas uh
and their atrocities in some of their
protests now I I don't think all those
people protesting are protesting uh that
that are Hamas again I think there's
there's a lot of complex issues here but
I do want to show you um some protest
this morning inside the Chamber of the
Senate and I believe it's very very
important that you see this I've got one
video here and this is um secretary
blinken went to the the Senate uh to
testify in front of of the uh the
committee here and the chair is Patty
Murray uh and Patty Murray is being very
cordial to the protesters um she's
handling the protesters with um with
humanity and she's trying to bring order
to the meeting because that's what
government has to have it it has to have
some sort of order to it uh to do the
official business of a of having
secretary blink and testify but I want
to show the audience this just a peek
into it and this was over over and over
this morning it it was strategic and
I'll I'll explain that um but this
protest to make sure that the
Palestinian people the the the civilians
the children there in Gaza aren't just
being slaughtered but listen thank you
very much uh chair Murray Vice chair
Collins uh distinguished members of the
Appropriations Committee thank you for
this opportunity to testify before you
[Applause]
today populated areas
stop supporting the genocide
and the people
ofe fire now save the children of Gaza
save the children of Gaza SE fire now
where is your pride
America now this was a strategic protest
they allowed these people to stay in the
room um as they one by one interrupt the
hearing and they escorted them out one
by one now this is this is this is
typical in Washington this happens all
the time this is a strategy that
protesters use to go into a public
hearing and to sit in the public hearing
um and to use this now what Republicans
typically do is they make that all of
them leave um but Patty Murray did not
do that this morning what Patty Murray
would do is she would suspend the
hearing uh let them protest on their way
out as they were escorted out um and
there again most of these prot
protesters that I listened to this
morning and watched this morning in this
hearing uh would get up and do their
protest at a certain point um and
because they have it planned uh the
protesters and again this is an American
experiment U we are supposed to allow
protest um we can have protest inside of
a hearing like this it can be cordial it
can be heard and I think these people
should be heard I don't think that we
should be silencing uh these people who
have these views on the war that's
happening in Palestine or the
Palestinian people and in Gaza because
there are Hamas is hiding behind
Palestinian children they are hiding
behind Palestinian civilians and those
palestin and they are firing from
positions that are getting the
Palestinian people in Gaza killed um and
and that that is important to know and
and that I actually agree with these
protesters that we shouldn't have uh
civilians death as we can avoid it but
in this situation right now Hamas is not
allowing us to avoid it um but I I I
want people to understand that I believe
in protest um even if I may not agree
with it I I believe in protest I believe
in your Liberty to protest and I believe
that Patty Murray because I was
listening this morning Texas Paul and
Patty Murray did such an excellent job
she would suspend the heing uh she would
wait for the protester to lead the
protester would be loud um they weren't
trying to move the entire group out uh
to prevent them from doing this Anthony
blinkin would pause he would let them
protest or whoever was testifying would
pause and let them protest um so I I
just want the audience to know that yes
there are there are protest going on and
they are pro Palestinian and and I
believe that we should free Palestine
from Hamas and I I believe those people
think the same thing but I want to show
the people that there is a way to
protest and there is a way for people
who control government to handle it and
Patty Murray did an excellent job this
morning even though she had a hearing to
run now
back to the uh the problem at hand here
is the war now Anthony blinkin was
testifying this morning in front of the
Senate Appropriations Committee uh and
to to tell them how how he is holding
the Israeli government accountable
because I think that is one of the other
important factors here is that we are
keeping a good eye on uh we are keeping
a good eye on U the Israeli government
and that because BB we know BB Netanyahu
isn't the uh the most crooked actor here
Amen brother there's a lot of there's a
lot of different things that are at
Factor here but Texas Paul did you see
or hear some of these protests this
morning from the Senate Appropriations
Committee it is such a good thing even
if you don't agree like I don't agree
with what that man said I don't I I
don't but the fact that he is able to
say it that he's able to get it out
there that's a good thing because
there's a lot of people that believe
what he's saying and if we don't talk
about it I mean he is drawing attention
to it he is drawing attention to that
talking point and that's a good thing
man that's why protests are a good thing
that that why the freedoms we have here
is a good thing and I and I'm with you
man I am so proud of Patty Murray and
the Democrats for allowing these people
you know they didn't get Draconian they
didn't just clear the room they didn't I
mean this is a good thing folks I mean
and I understand why that guy feels that
way I really do it's in our nature you
know we're not authoritarians by Nature
you know this is coming from the left
this is coming from the
left we care as people we give a [__] so
it makes these people really susceptible
to the right kind of propaganda you know
for the right it's fear it's fear and
authoritarianism and they eat it up if
you want to throw propaganda at the
left protect the children protect the
children somebody an evil entity is
killing children and that will get their
attention all the time but the fact that
we can have protest and that this stuff
can get said it allows us to talk about
what's really going on you know that
right now yeah Israel is not flattening
Gaza it's just not these are some pretty
damn surgical
incursions going on in G in Gaza they're
taking a lot of they're put their own
soldiers are putting themselves in
danger to make make this incursion
incursion less than it had it could be I
mean really and and Biden's done an
amazing job he has kept this conflict in
Gaza Hamas desperately wanted this to
spread you know when and Hezbollah
started you know making noise up north
what happened you know here come the
f-22s and and and uh whatnot off the the
f-35s off of uh the the Gerald R4
and started hitting Hezbollah locations
inside Syria and President Biden sent a
clear message this will not escalate so
yeah these these protests are amazing
fantastic it is really I'm and I'm with
you Tony I'm very proud of these people
I'm very proud of these people because
it shows who we are even if they're
wrong about it it shows what our values
are well and and I think I think um um
you know I I don't know if they're wrong
you know we're in we're in disagreement
with some things
because I I agree with him that that
children in Gaza and people in Gaza
shouldn't just be killed for the sake of
being killed but the reason why they're
being killed I think is uh where where
we have very strong disagreements and
and why the slaughter is happening um
you know this isn't you know and I see
some people in the chat and I appreciate
you coming here and and and voicing your
opinions in the chat this isn't Israelis
absolutely slaughtering people in Gaza
just so they can slaughter people on
Gaza if that was the truth they would
they they would have done leveled Gaza I
mean it would have been leveled they
they would have they wouldn't have given
them time to move um but I because I
want to show you guys something um that
I found this morning and it is a it is a
video uh you're you're muted there Texas
Paul uh it is a video of the tunnels uh
in in Gaza the Hamas tunnels now these
are strategic tunnels and folks this
isn't this isn't a situation where Hamas
is Hamas is just running out in the
streets in civilian clothes Hamas is a
very well equipped military unit um they
were elected to power in Gaza in 2007
now I'm gonna play this on mute um but
here's here's some footage from inside
now this now again you can say it's real
or it's not real this is RT that was
allowed it's kind of funny too Texas
ball that RT was the one right that they
were were they were the ones that were
allowed into the tunnels uh where Hamas
picks their strategic positions from but
you can tell these tunnels are are
underground they're about 60 meters
under the surface they're they're
concrete tunnels that they build little
by little it's just miles and miles of
tunnels that go throughout Gaza and they
and they're able to come to the surface
in strategic areas and they're able to
Fire and then hide back in their tunnels
um so that they're undercover now again
you know why he went down an air vent
there
Tony you know why he went down an air
vent there because the entrance to this
tunnel system is in the shifa hospital
in Gaza their biggest Hospital there's
an entrance in the bottom in the
basement of the shifa hospital and then
there are
other you froze up Texas Paul I'm not
sure um but yeah so the entrance of
these things are uh in hospitals and but
the point that I want to try to make
here is that not that not that a
governing body or a military unit
shouldn't have a way to uh fortify and
protect itself because it it should but
what I want people to understand is what
Hamas is doing and using the
infrastructure that they have to
convince people that it is the Israelis
killing civilians now is it is is it
Israeli Munitions that are doing it yes
but what you have to understand is when
Hamas comes to the surface these little
cockroach terrorists fascist cockroach
terrorists come to the surface and they
fire weapons they are picking the they
are picking the positions to fire from
um so that way the response is in that
particular area and I know a lot of
people disagree with this in the chat
they're saying they disagree with this
that oh it's propaganda that the
Israelis are doing this is not Israeli
propaganda folks this is not Israeli
propaganda this is video this is Hamas
video that that the Russian television
was was able to go get uh in the tunnels
this is not this is not Israeli
propaganda this is Straight From Russia
showing showing you their strategic
position now if you read the text and
you know you watch this video on Twitter
I've got I've got it posted from Twitter
um and just just a little point there
Tony the to agree with the point you're
making there Russia Today is Russia a
Russian Network owned by the Russian
government they don't do Israeli
propaganda and it's right there on the
front of the video this is an RT video
right there that little RT in the green
box is Russia today this is a Hamas
video produced in Con in conjunction
with the Russian government this is not
Israeli
propaganda now
again there is Israeli propaganda there
is there is Israeli propaganda on this
Israelis are producing propaganda
because BB Netanyahu is a [__]
scumbag okay I'm not I'm not g to say
that that Israel is innocent and they
have no blood on their hands ever in the
history of ever there's I can't say that
I cannot sit here and support uh Israel
in that they have never never ever ever
done anything bad when it comes to Gaza
City or the Palestinians or their
treatment of Palestinians to be frank
with you bb Netanyahu walked away from
this two-state solution many many years
ago at one point BB Netanyahu almost was
in agreeance of a two-state solution but
he has walked away from that and it is
one of the reasons why Hamas has been
able to [__] propagandize the
Palestinian people and convince them
that they're their protector from
someone like BB
Netanyahu because he's a piece of
[__] but we we cannot I think go ahead
BB Netanyahu is a is a he is I don't
like BB Netanyahu most is raes don't
like BB Netanyahu he he's uses he's the
lud is like Republicans they will do
anything to stay in power and they they
cheat in elections they really do that's
why BB netanyahu's still there um I'm in
agreeance with most Israelis that he's a
dick he is a complete dick that needs to
go 100% And and no Israel hasn't done
everything perfect but you know and and
that's the wrong way to put that
Israel's done some [__] up [__] that's
the right way to put that um but what
you see out of the Hamas propaganda is
like one-offs you know it's like these
aab people I can't agree with all cops
are bastards that's not true that's not
a TR that that is just not true there
are millions of engagements with the
police every day that are perfectly fine
they're perfectly cordial but the ones
you will see that will cause us to be
and rightfully so extremely pissed off
about are the ones that are [__]
awful and that's the same thing in
Israel you know yeah they [__] up they
do some bad things but it is not the
General State policy of Israel to commit
genocide in Gaza far from it you know
when Hamas took over Gaza
Israel withdrew they're talking about
this open air prison this is a Hamas run
prison the southern gate on this prison
is Egypt and Egypt runs that gate not
Israel the only Gates that Israel
control are the ones that come into
Israel so yeah there's a lot of talking
points that are just not true they're
just not and that's why I'm glad the
discussions are still ongoing people are
still talking about it because yeah I
agree with you 100% you know 99% of what
you said I totally agreed with you know
but
but yeah I [__] I've lost my point well
I mean I guess the I guess the point
here is and again I I've talked about
this about this conflict is that there's
a lot of things that are true all at the
same time uh and one of the things that
are true is that we have to have
Humanity here and I believe that the pro
Palestinian uh protest should continue
all around the world even though I don't
exactly agree with every single
sentiment and every single protest point
that they're trying to make um because I
think protest yeah go
ahead um I want to thank Grace Gracie in
in in in the chat for for bringing me
right back to where I was thinking
before there's a common phrase that even
Americans are chanting now pal um
Palestine will be free from The River To
The Sea uh and what you're talking about
with BB isn't embracing the two-state
solution BB is again complete dick but
he's dancing with a people in a
discussion about a two-state solution um
that chant Palestine will be free from
The River To The Sea um the river is the
River Jordan and the sea is the
Mediterranean that is the catchphrase of
most pal most Palestinians okay that
means Israel goes away that's what that
phrase means the destruction of Israel
so to and Hamas is brilliant Hamas runs
AA but all the infrastructure is run by
fata and fata buys their infrastructure
you know their their fuel and whatnot
from Israel Hamas gets to sit there and
say we're running things but they don't
actually have to do the administration
and when things go south like the water
gets cut off and whatnot they get to sit
there and say well that's bad guy Israel
it's like no man you ran this place
you've run this place for a quarter
century and every time something happens
you blame Israel but Israel doesn't run
this place you do you run it why didn't
you make it the whole Southern border is
Egypt if you don't like Israel why
aren't you there are power lines that go
to Egypt from Gaza why didn't you beef
that up why didn't you buy more
electricity you want you want to know
you want to know why you want to know
why this is such a such a back and forth
and a tug of war here
is because the Palestinian people really
are the cudel that is being used for the
Arab world to to try to eliminate Jewish
people in Israel I I I hate to be so
[__] outright with the truth but
that's the truth is Iran Egypt the
entire Arab War wants to use the
Palestinian people as a cudel and they
use they use Hamas as as the propaganda
outlet and the militant Outlet in Gaza
to to even Stoke that cudel even more
and to and to make it to where the
Palestinian people won't be free folks
as long as the Palestinian people are
not free from Hamas and the and the Arab
world
Israel Israel will be the enemy do you
see what I mean as long as the
Palestinians are oppressed or appear to
be oppressed or they actually oppressed
or in propaganda they're oppressed it
doesn't matter where in reality that
they are
oppressed but as long as the Palestinian
people aren't free if they were to be
free if they were to be free this hatred
of Israel would would
fade the wanting to exterminate Jewish
people in the Middle East would fade and
it would fade fast and that's the
problem is there's no freedom in the
Arab world I don't know what people are
I don't know if people study theology
but there is no freedom in the Arab
world and the only freedom in the Arab
world exists in a theology theatric
State a theologic and state that is
Israel that's the only one that appears
to be a democracy which with BB
Netanyahu and their theology because let
me tell you something this is what
religion does uh when your theology
starts to [__] poison your ideology
it starts to really really really T down
liberal democracy and that's the problem
things we don't agree on I'm still
trying to find those things you say we
don't agree on cuz I totally agree with
you the people
living in Gaza you know people are going
to say like this is me attacking them
I'm not attacking them in World War II
the people of Germany the overwhelming
majority of them believed the [__]
Hitler was selling they did they really
did I mean there was a lot of freaking
there's a reason Germany made that
propaganda illegal because there were a
lot of old folks that really really
believed that [__] and in in Gaza there
are a lot of people that believe the
[__] Hamas cells they just do there's a
lot of people in this country that
believes what Donald Trump and Maga
cells exactly there's a lot of people
that believe the [__] and and they
use Theology and they use uh someone
corrected me Theocratic was the word I
was looking for they use those
Theocratic ways to convince people of
propaganda uh Tina ask a good question
here on Facebook all right and again I
want to make sure that people out here
are having conversations because it's
obvious that me and Tina May disagree on
something because she's asking this
question she says why aren't the
Palestinians free in their country Tony
number one Palestinians don't have a
country and that is the design by the
Arab world folks the Arab world keeps
Palestinians from having their own
country it is not Israel It is Well it
has been Israel before in the past
Israel has agreed to two-state Solutions
there has been two-state Solutions talk
in Israel's government and as the Arab
world has walked away from the idea of
the Palestinians being free and then
just using them as a cudle to kill
Jewish people in Israel Israel walked
away from the two-state
solution okay now we can go through all
that context and we can go through all
that stuff but the but the point is this
is that I want the palast Indian people
to be free I want them to have actual
Liberty not not a a piece of ground
because folks land and [__] ground
and mountains and how much space you got
that ain't a country that ain't no
[__] country that ain't no country
without [__] Liberty you can have all
the land in the goddamn world that you
want and can have and can farm and can
take advantage of and take the [__]
resources out of and get rich and
prosper off of it but if you ain't got
Liberty you ain't got no [__] country
all you got is is either a religion or a
goddamn autocrat and a dictator or a
group of dictators telling you what the
[__] you can and what the [__] you can't
do and what you can think Liberty is the
key to a country Liberty is the key to
Freedom so Tina I I understand what
you're saying about their country but as
long as they don't have Liberty I don't
give a [__] who it's from Israel Hamas
uh the Arab world Jordan I I know most
people don't even know this is that
Jordan controlled the West Bank for
decades they controlled the West Bank
Texas Paul was talking about the
Jordanian River from The River To The
Sea the
Jordan had a big swath of land that
Israel Now controls in the West Bank um
so a lot of stuff can be true and again
this is very complicated issues it's not
as simple as one people against the
other and that's why I say have we gotta
have I may I throw one simple point out
Tony you were talking about why this is
happening one there are many reasons why
this is happening you're right it's
extremely complicated but one thing that
is not complicated is that Ismail hania
the head of Hamas is in 2014 is worth $5
million um today he's worth over a
billion uh Abu ma mazuk is worth over
three billion uh khed michall is worth
over five billion do they live in
Doha the head of the heads of Hamas they
live in Doha carer like kings
they don't even go back to Gaza but they
use the the Palestinian people like you
said as a cudgel they recruit from them
a many Palestinian Charities go directly
into these guys pockets they are getting
fabulously Filthy Rich pedling this
ideology and they don't even go to Gaza
they they don't um Michelle I don't
think has been there in five years and
he's the head of one of the heads of
Hamas he's the political one of R is
their political brand
I mean that is why folks everybody makes
Bank off the
Palestinians everybody [__] the
Palestinians and the Palestinian people
because they are covered in a blizzard
of
[__] don't even know who's [__]
them you know because right now Israeli
soldiers are not leveling Gaza that's a
talking point I keep hearing they're
leveling Gaza they're not they're very
surgically in Gaza right now going
through specific areas and specific
neighborhoods only that have Hamas
infrastructure in it that's where
they're going they're not leveling you
know from Rafa to Gaza City they're
not points are out there the
they I Texas Paul froze up again I think
I believe he is froze
which brings me which brings me to my
next uh Point here um because I want to
show you some Theocratic boneheads here
in this country who want us to be in a
religious War like in the region of the
Middle East has been for for centuries
here is now this this guy uh Texas PA
this guy is um a Texas State Rep his
name is Matt schaer I don't know if you
know Matt schaer or heard of Matt schaer
there in Texas but here's Matt schaer
let's see what he says about the Bible
and what we should do with government in
the Bible I think you need to really
understand what the Bible says I really
think that you need to be well grounded
in your
theology and the reason I tell that to
uh a young person is that if you're
developing your world view with respect
to politics by what you absorb through
social media or CNN or Fox News or a
political science course you take at the
University you're starting in the wrong
place there is so much practical wisdom
that's found in the Bible for justice
for stewardship for work for the family
stewardship of the earth um paying taxes
all these things there are solid
Biblical principles that are founded in
our theology as Christians and so if
you're thinking about getting involved
in politics make sure that you
understand what the Bible says on the
issue before you try to speak into the
public space okay so this guy is saying
what he's saying is hey uh if you really
want to speak in the public space
especially if you want to engage in
politics what you should do is not not
really form a ideology but make sure
your ideology is very well very well
versed in a theology um which is
obviously one of the problems that we
have uh right now in this conflict in
Gaza uh it's rooted brother in this that
so true well and and I think when when
they want us to govern they want to
govern us Matt schaer here because he's
an elected official this isn't just some
[__] this is an elected official
in the state of Texas this guy is
responsible for going to the capital of
Texas and legislating for his constit
consents and he wants to govern US based
on his religion and there is a document
in this country I forget what it's
called but there is a document in this
country that talks a little bit about
what they can govern based on their
religion it doesn't allow it is is the
point they cannot govern US based on
their religion okay and that is what
makes um um our
democracy uh
unique it does make us unique and makes
us different from a democracy like
Israel from a place like Jordan from a
place like Egypt from a place like Gaza
it makes us completely different um it
is a different culture it is a different
Society it is a different world viiew
but this guy this guy here this Matt
schaer this [__] scumbag this weirdo
this Bible weirdo who wants to [__]
pass laws based on his religion to tell
us what we can and can't do this guy
wants what they have over there and he
wants it here this is the stuff this is
the [__] this is the talk this is the
type this is the type of discourse that
leads to what is happening in Gaza where
children are being slaughtered because
Hamas is picking firing positions so
that Israelis will fire back in
retaliation and kill their civilians and
then they then Hamas can say oh look the
Israelis killed hundreds of
children you know that that Al Ali uh
Hospital explosion that went you know
viral and turned out to be did you know
the Palestinian Islamic
Jihad launched those those missiles from
a
cemetery they didn't pull a Hamas they
didn't put their rocket launcher in the
middle of a populated area they launched
from a cemetery because they knew the
Israelis would destroy their their
launchers they knew they would I mean
it's like not everybody does this stuff
man even that terrorist organization
Palestinian Islamic
Jihad understands don't [__] put your
rocket launchers in an apartment
building full of
children because Israel cannot the Iron
Dome isn't
foolproof you know you're launching
missiles at children they're going to
fire back and if you put your missile
launchers with children those children
are going to die and the people that are
defending themselves from your Rockets
didn't kill those children you did you
know Tony if you and I were at War and I
was outside your house with a [__]
marava tank and I told you shoot at me
and I will kill you and your family's in
your house with you and you start
shooting at my
tank and I blow a hole through the
center of your [__] house did I kill
your kids or did you kill your kids well
that's a good question I mean that's a
good question here here is um now I
don't I don't know if you know Jessica
but Jessica is one of the only ones on
the five that's got any kind of [__]
brains um and she's usually the liberal
Defender she's the punching bag on there
to the five but they don't I'm surprised
they haven't removed her from this de of
the of the five because she does this so
well but I think this clip of what she's
talking about about anti-Semitism raging
around the world um I want to show it to
you because I think she comes from a
unique perspective because I think
Jessica is a Jewish woman so let me play
this that maybe a silver lining in this
is that most Holocaust surbers are not
alive to see what's going on today it's
horrifying on every level this is
rehashing what went on in the 30s
heading into the Holocaust obviously
there were reports this weekend now that
Hamas has started openly bragging by the
way about their crimes because that was
one of the currents of all of this that
it wasn't real right people who were
denying what they had done on October
7th and it's hard I think to have a a
winning piece of the terror attack in
terms of this is the most horrific thing
I've ever heard but now there's a report
that um a husband he was murdered then
his wife was raped and they baked their
baby in the oven and kept the woman
alive so that she could hear the screams
of her child melting and a signature of
the Holocaust is obviously that they put
Jews in the oven so here we are now that
language is deserved that we're talking
about it what happened in the Russian
airport reminiscent of the pograms we're
heading back in a very very dangerous
Direction it's heartbreaking between
Cornell kids uh locked in the kosher
dining hall Cooper Union Jewish kids
locked in the library faculties clearly
not up to the task in terms of being
able to deal with this few exceptions I
think the letter that the President of
emry University wrote was really
fantastic and quite
declarative uh so there is Jessica on
and this is decoding Fox News provided
that clip on on Twitter um so there's a
lot of different narratives there's a
lot of different perspectives and
because this is a very complex issue as
as religion and War are complex issues
um and and again I know the the audience
isn't going to agree with everything I
say I know the audience isn't going to
agree with every single one of my
opinions and that's okay I want you to
be here I want you to desent in the in
the chat I want you to tell me how you
think I want you to tell me how you feel
that that may not necessarily mean what
you're going to say is going to change
my mind but I want to listen to you as
well as I what I know what I say is not
going to exactly change your mind but I
appreciate every single one of you
coming here even though you disagree
with me on some of these uh issues that
are happening or maybe we don't disagree
we just have a different perspective of
it that we are able to have this
conversation so I I respect that um I
want to move on though because I have a
few things I want to show because I
gotta goof on some people a little bit
here H I can't be all serious here on
the Tony Michaels podcast can I add can
I while you look that up can I add a
point yeah go ahead um what you just saw
in dagistan that was fomented from a
telegram Channel they've track back
where where it started these people how
they were involved in it what how how
they were told to go there there's a
telegram channel That Feeds propaganda
from Russia to the United States to
White
supremacists um that telegram channel is
what is who told these people that a
flight was coming in from Tel Aviv
because all these people didn't just you
know sit there and follow the airport to
you know hey what flights are coming in
today no they were told that flight was
coming in from Tel Aviv on that telegram
Channel and that's what they responded
to it was Putin propaganda that put him
there it is Putin propaganda that's
pushing a lot of the false narratives
that you're
seeing coming out and what's going on in
Gaza this is really a sop folks it
really is a scop well and and again what
Jessica was alluding to is that
anti-Semitism is it's so easy to get it
to catch hold because that c has been
out of the bag um before the Holocaust
but since the Holocaust that cat is out
of the bag so and Jesus Jesus Christ
Tony they're painting star stars of
David on Jewish people's businesses and
homes in Paris right that's happening
the last couple days that's been the
newest thing is they they take a
template put it up spray blue paint on
it for and and paint a star David on
Jewish people's homes what do you think
that's there for right well and the
other the other this is the other reason
why I'm I'm not excited to be Netanyahu
is the the leader of Israel at this
point because of his right-wing fascist
views um but speaking of fascist I got
to move on because this is hilarious
Texas Paul this is our opposition folks
here in this country as far as politics
is concerned right okay this account is
the RNC research account okay this is
their official RNC research again this
is the Republicans in this country and
this is our opposition and I'm laughing
because this is the tweet that they sent
out it says Biden drops candy after he
is startled by a kid's Halloween costume
I I don't know what I don't know what
the hell they're talking about he he
clearly has a couple boxes of candy he
drops one he hands one to a kid and then
he picks it what are they talking
about this is the [__] they're trying to
[__] spin these are the lies that
somehow this video here proves that Joe
Biden shouldn't be what are they talk
like literally they're just taking video
and they're like how can we make the
Sheep believe that Joe Biden is feeble
in this clip or something this is weird
to me this is [__] weird yeah it this
that that site is I man I call them out
all the time on social media they post
the dumb as [__] I'm I am seriously
waiting for a post from these people
that just says do you know Biden farts
do you know he farts stinky old farts
you know I mean just the stupidest [__]
that they say
I mean and sometimes it's hilarious they
own themselves they put one out just the
other day where they were just like
Biden you know I forget what it was say
Biden did this that and the other oh
yeah it was about the strikes in Syria
where you know Biden's been containing
all this Middle East [__] uh Hezbollah
tried to get involved so boom Gerald R
Ford they laid down God and thunder
right there so you want in we're here
and and he containing this inside Gaza
and they're like Biden conducts air
strik air strikes in Syria and and
Strikes Hezbollah and he's trying to
start World War III and it's
like when was that a bad
thing right right he Hezbollah is a
terrorist organization speaking of
terrorist um they desperately want back
the terrorist here in this the domestic
terrorist here in this country
desperately want back Texas Paul The
Narrative that Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden took money from China then there's
a there they took $40 million did you
know that they took $40 million exit
well maybe it's 50 it could be 75 by
today I'm sure today at 75 million but
Texas Paul so much money has been
changed into the Biden's hands but you
know what James Biden wrote Joe Biden a
check for $200,000 I don't know where
the rest of that $75 million went I
don't know if it went all to hookers and
blow for Hunter but but you know what's
funny is box box judge box wine here uh
she's trying to explain the check but
I'm going to give you a little bit of
facts that I think is funny about Judge
Perino here and Donald Trump and some uh
some [__] Financial crimes but let's
listen to this clip give me a break of
course they're gonna they're gonna
subpena Hunter but you know what's so
special
about maybe there we go maybe I don't
know the loan check that went from James
to Joe
repayment of a loan prove to me it was a
loan I want to see the loan document I
want to know what the interest was I
want to know the payment schedule I want
to know what would happen What would if
there were a penalty is there a
prepayment penalty I mean the 2,000 and
one Fell Swoop hey that just reads
repayment of a loan that doesn't mean
anything you know what there is there's
a there's a guy she was married to that
Donald Trump gave last minute pardon for
for this very thing for this very thing
that she's describing her ex-husband was
pardoned by Donald Trump speakings of
pardon pardon the interruption here um
but I think um I think wait do I hear
some do I hear some
music is with the
[Music]
last is with the we're going to get a
Cheeto
chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
all right all right all right turn turn
turn what's up man what's up what's up
dudes how's it going how's it going
we're just talking about Judge boxwine
your favorite person over there on the
five oh boy yeah judge Janine Peru well
let me let me show you another video
here of Jesse Waters because he gets
really pissed off this when he blew a
gasket oh my God he's so gun he's so mad
at Jessica like
and she's like trying to get a word in
but she's like you're just a hysterical
little child like you're not even you're
not even doing anything here but here
watch this is that your Smoking
Gun is that your Smoking Gun Jessica
because you said that was a Smoking Gun
if money went from overseas directly
into Joe Biden's bank account if a check
comes out at some
point from that
Avenue is that a Smoking Gun okay um so
two things yes or no yes or no no it's
not it's not wait whoa whoa Jessica for
a year you said oh the money never hit
his bank account what if I have a check
that hits his bank account that comes
from overseas is that not a Smoking Gun
oh okay is he in elected office and did
he do something about it so that check
that 2018 check when he was not doing
anything except hanging around and there
was an explanation for it so if you get
a check you know what I love I love that
they put the check up for Fox newers to
see and they're like look it's to Joe
Biden for 200 Grand but they don't
highlight the loan repayment or that it
was written on March 1st in 2018 I like
that part I like that part but they
still provide the nonsmoking gun
evidence here now it goes on and Jesse
gets more upset he gets more pissed
because Jessica makes I don't know valid
points and it just really tears up his
entire [__] narrative that somehow my
[__] narrative yes or no damn it
right right but Gabe Sanchez this is
Jesse Waters because he's about as good
at having a a a a decent conversation
with someone as he is like letting the
tire out of uh or the air out of a tire
so that he can hit on a woman which is
thing yeah I mean not only that but he's
also as good as trying to be a
pro-slavery
apologist by saying that black people
benefited slaves benefited from
slavery um later down the line and and
that one I mean like dude look Jesse
Waters should have taken his mother's
advice that was live on air do not bring
up any divisive comments there's already
a ton of polarization that's happened in
this country there's no need to fuel
conspiracy theories and to drive even
more hate it's not very hard but for
Jesse Waters I mean God I don't know
what happened in his life that he
developed into such a [__] [__] but
this guy has nothing but
conspiracies uh lies and also misogyny
mixed into one whenever he's on the air
it's crazy but totally on brand for Fox
News well and for Republican men in
general I mean really that's that's what
it is oh wait got wait we got a we got a
we got a picture uh in here is um here's
Jessica being surrounded by uh the
clowns there at the five she's trying to
be reasonable she's trying to be [__]
reasonable but the the clowns this you
know I'm gonna say this looks like
Jessica and it also looks like the other
the other [__] on the five I mean
they all kind of that's the thing the
Republican party is full of clowns stuck
in a clown car and after a while they
begin to look the same they do they do
well I mean how could you not when you
say some stupid [__] but you know what
they're saying truth out loud I I played
a clip for you the other day Gabe
Sanchez where um they were expelling it
was on Friday they were they're trying
to expel George Santos right um and in
the clip it was fascinating to listen to
one of the Republicans go to the floor
and just like [__] out facts out of
their mouth because I've never seen a
republican tell so much Truth uh
especially about George santz like hell
only only when it benefits them right
they got their fascist speaker in place
and now they're like well do we really
need George Santos I mean the guy is now
currently in died on 23 felony counts I
mean go you know I just I just wish what
they would do is do you know have equal
opportunity there so Republicans would
go to the floor and read all the charges
against their Republican colleague
George Santos but also go to the floor
and read all the charges that are
against their musolini Jesus mango mus
speaking of felony counts and
superseding indictments let me tell you
A Tale of an orange man with small
little hands let's drop some facts but
you know there are some Republicans that
are doing this here's Tim Scott I know
you might not know who this is I think
he's still running for president maybe
Mike Pence dropped out I don't know if
Tim Scott will be next but listen to
what Tim Scott had to say Texas Paul
you're muted that's why no one can hear
you sorry I muted a minute cuz I was
slurping coffee I'm sorry isn't this
isn't this the guy that says he's a
virgin with a girlfriend who happens to
be a middle said he lost his virginity
at the age of 31 which you know hey man
you know to each their own if that's
what you're into but well if I look like
that I might not get late either
so but he is yes he is the one who said
he is now dating a um cute or beautiful
I forget the adjective Christian
girl no one he said girl I'm pretty sure
he said girl look all I'll say is his
girlfriend is as real as Mike Johnson's
fake son that's true well a guy this age
does not should not be describing anyone
he's dating as a girl that's it's red
flags but I I'm I'm gonna show you a
clip where Tim Scott he may be lying
about his girl that he's dating but he's
not lying here and this is fascinating
listen to him tell the truth it's only
like 13 seconds listen I don't think he
can win
but but but you have to be able to win
in Georgia I don't think you can win in
Georgia I think you have to be to win in
Pennsylvania there there are there are
states in this country that we lost in
2022 I don't oh boy H and he's talking
about Donald Trump there uh let me give
let me Tim Scott a little bit more truth
because he says he doesn't think he
could win he's not going to win that he
won't he can't win he won't win he's a
[__] four time six time 12 time
however many you want to count loser and
he will continue to be a [__] loser
but they love losers they [__] love
losers it's not it's not just he I mean
yes uh you know occasionally these
Republicans bring up valid points not
realizing that it's actually a dig
against their own party right but it's
not just 2022 midterms it was 2020 it
was the 2018 midterms I mean look you
have people like
um uh Bill bar and and other
uh who admit that they are losing that
they have lost the last three elections
under Donald Trump like the Fanfare and
the and the uh the push the drive behind
Donald Trump to say oh we're gonna we're
gonna get people to vote this way to
vote Republican in all these states and
counties and all that [__] what ends
up happening is under Trump 2018 2020
2022 and it's going to happen again in
2024 because again they run on dumb
[__]
propaganda uh type
of
points it's gonna happen a fourth time
in a row that under Donald Trump or
under his leadership they're going to
lose and Tim Scott is right about 2022
but he forgot the other two years
previous and the year after which will
be this upcoming election Well here
here's another Republican on CNN with
Anderson Cooper talking about it do you
still consider yourself a republican so
it's a tough question I do only in that
because I don't want to give up on that
fight I this country needs two healthy
parties a healthy Democratic party not
the Republican so I'm not going to give
up that title a country needs a good
conservative and a good liberal movement
at any time in their lives I so I I
still have the title but I voted
Democratic last election cycle if it's
Trump against Joe Biden I'll vote
Democratic this coming one because
Anderson I really believe it's down to
one issue on the ballot and not taxes
not even abortion nothing the one issue
is do you believe in democracy or do you
believe in authoritarianism and I think
that's the only thing we should be
voting on oh boy this guy I tell you
what you know I like what he's saying
here but he's so [__] full of [__] I
I just can't give up on being Republican
the [__] out of here man you know you
know that the Republican party's dead
give it up it's it's ridiculous that
this guy even continues this kind of
narrative and but you know Adam s kin
singer runs into the truth you know like
the rest of them do and he he
understands what's at stake and I know
the same it's the same it's the same as
the um as the Lincoln project right they
we are the enemy of our enemy is our
friend right now and this is another
example where as soon as the opportunity
strikes and they have removed Donald
Trump and anyone else who's pushing this
tyrannical authoritarian right-wing
extremist type of view because they want
more of that center right type of
Republican that Ronald Reagan we want
that bush we want you know [__]
Abraham Lincoln even though that's the
opposite of what they are we want that
bush you just said that want that
bush um but when you you have to
remember that like while right now great
that's another vote of a republican who
is against Donald Trump because he's
just insane and it leads to something
that's
extremist as soon as that threat is
removed it will shift to the other side
and people need to be careful about that
stuff when they're for that as I mean
look look at Steve Schmidt that's what I
was just gonna say yep Steve Schmidt is
throwing his hat in the ring because
he's being paid a high dollar Consulting
fees for some [__] named Dean
Phillips um Gabe Sanchez you're up right
after this on YouTube and twitch what
was that live everyone stay tuned Gabe
get the hell over there and get your mic
and your camera and all your [__] ready
because we're going to send the audience
your way as soon as we're done here on
YouTube get your ass over there get get
the out it's been it's been a pleasure
boys yeah get the hell out of here get
the hell out of here Texas Paul Gabe
Sanchez is gonna be up right after this
was what was that line for a full hour
he's every Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday he does his own live show for a
full hour on YouTube and twitch and we
shoot right to him um and I also want to
remind the audience get down in the
description below or if you can't if
you're not on YouTube and it's not in
the description go to Real Texas
paul.com that's
realex paul.com follow Paul there Paul
you're going to have your show tomorrow
on Wednesdays as you always do I'm sure
how has the show been going on Sunday
and Wednesdays it's been going great
when the the Israeli thing came up there
was you know I took a little hit there
because you know I you know me I don't
I'm not a fainting Diva I blow torch out
what I think and I pissed a lot of
people off but it's been picking back up
again I mean I lost a little bit of my
but they're coming back so it's good
it's good but you know what before we
get out of time that logo I want to go
back to your hoodie for a second because
that logo on your hoodie is absolutely
the truth this machine kills fascist I
mean not literally but you know I mean
it does it kills I don't know you can
pick it up and beat someone pretty good
with it I'm sure you can you know really
get someone good on the Noggin with it
I'm just saying I am trying to be the
good guy here I don't use it that way I
don't use it that way I'm just saying
I'm just saying but what was your point
sorry I didn't mean to it's a fantastic
point it really is you are spot on with
this I'm so glad to see that that that
that's going to be one of your new logos
is you know it is Fant you should make
that your new logo man just my advice
that is a fantastic logo and it's the
truth these microphones kill fascism you
know it used to be this damn cow toow
corporate media that used to feed people
[__] all the time and that's how the
Republicans got away with this and
they're going nuts because they can't
figure out why they're not getting away
with it anymore you know good job my
friend good job that is a great thank
you well if you want to grab your your
this machine kills fascist Tony Michaels
podcast logo on sweaters on t-shirts on
hoodies go to the Tony michaels.com pan
down you'll see the tattoo merch
collection there it's called the tattoo
merch and the reason why is because I'm
going to get it tattooed right here on
my damn arm and I'm going to get the
Statue of Liberty tattooed on my inner
forearm so don't miss out on that don't
miss out on the merch also go grab you
some even my dog hates Ted Cruz a lot of
people are liking this we have sold a
ton of even my dog hates Ted Cruz merch
so get your merch today go to the Tony
michaels.com visit Real Texas fall.com
and don't forget to come back here
tomorrow rather you're on YouTube
Facebook or twitch same time same place
Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michel and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking